antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction hervé claude bonsoir les
cartes sont redistribuées au proche
orient le roi hussein a rompu les liens
entre son pays la jordanie et la
cisjordanie voisine territoires occupés
par israël
cette décision met israël et les
palestiniens
au pied du mur
non
nouvel attentat des terroristes
d'irlande et de lire à cette fois c'est
en pleine ville contre une caserne de
londres il y à un mort et 15 blessés
les propositions de le pen à la droite
il souhaite des listes uniques de
l'opposition pour les municipales il
veut lui même s'attaquer à la mairie
demain les organes d'animaux grèce et
sur l'homme sait peut être demain et
chirurgiens londonien explore une
nouvelle technique l'ol paie s'interroge
israël hésite les américains sont
perplexes en tout cas la décision du roi
hussein de jordanie a surpris tout le
monde le roi hussein en effet décidé de
rompre les liens qu'ils étaient très
forts entre son propre pays et la
cisjordanie
de l'autre côté du jourdain un
territoire actuellement occupé par
israël
c'est une décision historique c'est en
tout cas une décision qui redistribue
les cartes dans cette région car la
cisjordanie c'est vous le savez ce
territoire où des affrontements
quotidiens ont lieu en ce moment c'est
aussi le territoire où pourraient un
jour être créer un état palestinien
alors pour bien comprendre la décision
du roi hussein il est nécessaire de
faire un retour en arrière historique
jacques merlino en annonçant hier soir à
man la rupture des liens légaux et
administratifs entre la jordanie et la
cisjordanie le roi hussein a pris une
décision historique et important
puisqu'elle se traduit par un abandon de
souveraineté
la cisjordanie est ce petit territoire
de 6000 kilomètres carré délimité par le
jourdain la mer morte et israël a annexé
par la jordanie en 1950 elle est occupée
par les israéliens depuis la guerre de
juin 1967
dès lors son statut va devenir complexe
la loi jordanienne continuent de s'y
appliquer mais le pouvoir réel est
détenu par l'armée israélienne
le gouvernement jordanien paye les
salaires de près de 20 mille
palestiniens occupés des tâches
administratives et d'enseignement mais
voit son autorité s'effilocher au profit
de noël paix à cet imbroglio s'ajoutent
encore le fait que les israéliens depuis
20 ans multiplie les colonies
d'implantations et tissent des liens de
plus en plus étroits entre leurs
économies et celle la cisjordanie
cinquante cinq mille colons sont
aujourd'hui installés sur cette terre à
laquelle ils ont redonné les noms
bibliques de judée et de samarie
l'abandon de ce territoire par la
jordanie va d'abord se traduire par un
véritable problème financier
le plan quinquennal de développement qui
devait être assuré par la jordanie à
hauteur de 1 milliard 300 millions de
dollars et supprimé
de même le gouvernement jordanien a
laissé entendre qu'il ne paierait plus
les fonctionnaires palestiniens soit un
manque à gagner d'environ 70 millions de
dollars par an en laissant les mains
libres à yasser arafat le roi hussein
lui lance donc un défi celui de faire
vivre une communauté de 800000 personnes
alors voyons tout de suite les réactions
des intéressés et tout d'abord les
palestiniens qui sont les premiers
concernés toujours rien du côté de l'ol
paie qui bien sûr s'est réuni
immédiatement en cisjordanie même c'est
l'inquiétude du côté palestinien il ya
eu aujourd'hui d'ailleurs des incidents
sporadiques en cisjordanie et à gaza ce
même jour d'ailleurs les habitants de
ces territoires observer scrupuleusement
un mot d'ordre de grève générale
écoutez maintenant les réactions des
palestiniens qui vivent aujourd'hui en
cisjordanie
charles enderlin pour l'instant le roi
hussein n'a pas coupé tous les ponts
avec la cisjordanie et gaza
les pastèques palestinienne continue
d'être exporté vers à mal une rupture
des relations économiques entre les deux
rives du jourdain serait une catastrophe
pour les palestiniens des territoires
qui sont très très inquiets
je suis pas sûr que lohan paix sera en
mesure de prendre la relève
je sais que la déclaration du rhône ne
veut pas dire la rupture totale dans un
moment comme ça dans une situation qui
est très délicate pour la résistance
nationale du peuple palestinien les
partisans de l'ol paie comme rama
signora sont eux satisfaits et parle
d'un moment historique dans le
soulèvement palestinien
axa la jordanie accepte définitivement
le principe de l'indépendance pour les
palestiniens
pour ma part je ne suis pas inquiet des
conséquences économiques ou juridiques
que pourrait avoir la rupture décidé par
le roi hussein nous trouverons toujours
une solution en cisjordanie on attend à
présent la réaction de l'ol paie si les
palestiniens sont plutôt inquiet en
israël on est méfiant
israël se trouve maintenant au pied du
mur et selon les clivages politiques les
réactions ne sont pas identiques et
goûter pour la droite israélienne la
décision du roi de jordanie est une
bonne nouvelle
il sera shamir le premier ministre s'est
empressé d'affirmer que l'option
jordanienne de son rival travailliste
shimon peres est bien morte
pas question de négocier avec l'ol paie
à qui le souverain hachémite a laissé la
responsabilité de la cij hors d'âge
benyamin nétanyahou l'étoile montante du
likoud la droite a déclaré dès hier soir
ce que toute concession territoriale
israélienne est plus que jamais
impossible à gauche les travaillistes
sont dans l'embarras à quelques mois
d'une élection législative cruciale
leurs propositions de régler le problème
palestinien dans le cadre d'un accord
avec la jordanie vient de voler en
éclats alors tout en espérant que le roi
hussein n'a pas dit son dernier mot
il parle de révisions déchirantes
certains même de négocier avec les
palestiniens
une nouvelle donne au proche-orient donc
mais tout d'abord pierre serra le retour
sur le devant de la scène du roi hussein
de jordanie va effectivement dans la
mesure où la décision du roi leur place
sur le devant de la scène justement un
moment où il ne prétend plus à un rôle
de premier plan dans la région
c'est assez extraordinaire mais vous
savez le roi de jordanie est un monarque
courageux et un habile politique à la
fois lors ces décisions est avant tout
historique il renonce à des territoires
et des populations que son grand père le
roi abdallah avait annexé en 1950 il ya
près de 40 ans et qui sont occupés de
dire par israël depuis 21 ans
mais en fait sa décision est un défi un
défi est teintée d'amertume
le message à l'ol paie et aux arabes
d'ailleurs éclaire bien puisque vous
prétendez pouvoir régler le problème me
pèse sur moi balesi fait mais on va voir
jusqu'où pouvait aller c'est sa décision
à partir de là on peut penser que le roi
hussein et prend des risques parce qu il
embarrasse tout bon les américains les
israéliens et des palestiniens on vient
de le voir
donc c'est le risque c'est en même temps
l'habileté parce que il peut croire il
peut espérer peut-être même que tôt ou
tard
or viendra le chercher un défi donc pour
le roi hussein mais peut-être aussi une
décision de politique intérieure car le
roi en jordanie n'a pas envie d'être
débordés par les palestiniens qui sont
très nombreux en jordanie
bah ils sont nombreux ça mais pour la
question c'est oui et non oui dans la
mesure où si vous voulez d'abord il faut
que nous faut se rappeler le la décision
de bruxelles en fait est dictée par
l'intifada le soulèvement palestinien
territoires occupés
ces populations ont rejeté russeil n'ont
jamais voulu de lui n'ont jamais fait
appel à lui et donc amèrement déçu ça
c'est la première chose
et à partir de là il peut effectivement
et là la réponse à votre question serait
oui et prendre le risque de se dire ne
pas prendre le risque en disant avec 65%
de palestiniens si georges jordan enfin
pour 65% qui occupent des postes clés de
l'administration et partout s'ils sont
solidaires de leurs frères et
territoires occupés ils peuvent laisser
mon régime mais la réponse à votre
question et non en cas inverse si comme
le croit le roi hussein ces palestiniens
là ne veulent pas prendre le risque de
perdre à la fois une certaine stabilité
et une relative disons prospérité pour
soutenir simplement leurs frères et
c'est ça son calcul voilà alors à partir
de là on peut penser qu'effectivement il
a et d'ailleurs il a pris soin d avertir
ces gens il leur a dit cette décision ne
vous concerne pas dans la mesure où vous
tenez bien merci pierre voilà donc ce
qu'on pouvait dire sur ce dossier de la
jordanie et de la cisjordanie
les terroristes d'irlandais ont frappé
une nouvelle fois depuis quelques
semaines lire a intensifié ses attaques
contre l'armée britannique en général à
l'extérieur du pays cette fois l'ira a
frappé au coeur une caserne londonienne
dans la circonscription de margaret
thatcher
il y a
morts et 15 blessés dominique verdeilhan
un des quartiers d'habitation de la
caserne inglis a été complètement
détruit par la déflagration l'explosion
qui s'est produite à 7h ce matin a
soufflé les deux étages d'un des
bâtiments et provoqué un incendie
cinquante personnes se trouvaient dans
l'enceinte militaire au moment de
l'explosion
un soldat a été tué et 15 autres ont été
blessés
ils souffrent pour la plupart de
brûlures et deux d'entre eux ont été
hospitalisés dans un état grave
la caserne ne bénéficiait pas d'une
protection particulière en raison de son
caractère peu stratégiques et les berges
le régiment royal des femmes de l'armée
de terre et sert de dépôt postale la
caserne inglis est situé dans le
quartier nord de londres réputée pour sa
forte concentration d'immigrés irlandais
un quartier qui se trouve être en plein
coeur de la circonscription
parlementaire du premier ministre madame
thatcher lira revendique là sa première
attaque d'envergure sur le sol
britannique
depuis l'attentât d'octobre 1984 contre
le grand hôtel de brighton où madame
thatcher était descendu avec les membres
de son gouvernement pour le congrès du
parti conservateur un attentat qui avait
fait 5 morts et 30 blessés depuis 1984
quand landière l'avait toujours déjouer
les tentatives terroristes de l'ira sur
la grande île mais depuis plusieurs mois
la police britanniques craignaient une
reprise des attentats autre explosion
mais cette fois c'est pour la paix cela
s'est passé au kazakhstan une région de
l'union soviétique c'était l'explosion
de quatre missiles détruit
volontairement par les soviétiques dans
le cadre de l'accord américano
soviétique sur le désarmement surtout
une dizaine d'observateurs américains
étaient présents
c'était prévu par les accords les
américains ont montré le chemin
aujourd'hui et soviétiques relever le
défi gilles rabin
parole tenue défi relevé le jour même où
il faisait détruire en asie centrale
devant des spécialistes américains les 4
premiers euromissiles et 16 12 le
ministre soviétique de la défense le
général iazov confirmait qu'il réservait
à son homologue américain le secrétaire
d'état frank carlucci un programme à
faire rêver qui va permettre au patron
de la défense américaine de découvrir
deux ou trois des secrets les mieux
gardés de l'armée rouge non seulement en
karoutchi pourra visiter une base navale
sur la mer noire
non seulement il pourra assister aux
manoeuvres de la division d'élite de
goubing cas mais on lui permettra aussi
de découvrir le tout dernier bombardier
nucléaires stratégiques soviétique le
blackjack que personne en occident
jamais pu voir la guerre du vietnam n'en
finit plus de faire des ravages aux
états unis voir tous les films elles
étaient les séries télévisées qui sont
consacrés dernière polémique en date
celle sur l'agent orange un produit
chimique utilisé dans les bombardements
américains au vietnam il aurait provoqué
des malformations chez les enfants des
gi's jane fonda qui récemment a regretté
d'avoir autant militer contre la guerre
du vietnam jane fonda participe en ce
moment à des fêtes pour aider les
vétérans du vietnam
reportage ponant elle s'appelle brandi
si belle à 8 ans et s'accroche
désespérément à son père randy est né à
moitié sourde et aveugle
ils sont 64 mille enfants comme elle mal
formé de naissance leur père tous des
anciens du vietnam les ses vétérans à
cusset l'agent orange un défoliant à
base de dioxyde déversés sur les forêts
les plaines du vietnam qui est à
l'origine de ces malformations
rien n'est encore prouvé
scientifiquement mais les présomptions
sont fortes depuis dix ans ces soldats
perdus et c'est d'alerter l'opinion
publique américaine
les gens voudraient que ce problème du
vietnam disparaissent moi pas question
d'abandonner
je suis américain et je me suis battu
pour ce pays
ce soir là les vétérans avaient organisé
une grande fête pour collecter de
l'argent afin de faire soigner ses
enfants
en effet le gouvernement ne veut pas
payer les frais d'hospitalisation
vedette de cette fête deux grandes stars
du cinéma
jane fonda et robert de niro et jane
fonda n'a pas voulu donner d'interview
c'est en effet la première fois que
l'actrice américaine participer à ce
genre de manifestation jane fonda
célèbre pour ses prises de positions
anti américaines pendant la guerre du
vietnam
mais les anciens eux n'ont pas oublié ce
qu'elle a fait n'était pas tout bon ou
tout mauvais mais il est temps pour un
américain et surtout pour un chrétien de
pardonner
lui pardonner à elle d'avoir fait une si
grave erreur d'accord mais ce que je ne
lui pardonnerai jamais c'est d'avoir
fait tant de tort aux combattants sur le
terrain
douze ans après la fin de la guerre le
vietnam reste encore une profonde
déchirure
le reste de l'actualité maintenant a
commencé avec françois corner par les
pourparlers pour un cessez le feu dans
la guerre entre l'iran et l'irak et
justement aujourd'hui
l'onu relève l'utilisation de plus en
plus massive d'armes chimiques rencontre
retardée en effet sans explication
aujourd'hui nations-unies entre le
secrétaire général de l'onu et le
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
dans le cadre des pourparlers de paix
iran irak une ombre de taille au tableau
l'utilisation de plus en plus intense
selon un rapport d'experts des nations
unies sur place des armes chimiques dans
la guerre du golfe l'irak est en
accusation intense émotion ce matin au
cimetière communal de vitry sur seine en
région parisienne pour l'inhumation
d'isabelle bismuth la jeune française de
21 ans trouvé avec huit autres personnes
dans l'attentât du city offre hausse le
11 juillet dernier au sud d'athènes une
victime mise en cause un moment par la
police grecque à cause d'une photo prise
au cours d'une partie car avec l'un des
terroristes
indignation de la fédération nationale
de la presse française du président de
la république du ministre de la culture
et de la communication télégramme de
soutien du syndicat de la presse
quotidienne de personnalités socialistes
et de l'opposition au mensuel blog
dévasté hier par une explosion d'origine
criminelle
aucune piste sérieuse pour l'instant sur
les mobiles de cet attentat transports
en commun électricité poste plus cher
les os du mois d'août pénaliseront
particulièrement au chapitre des
transports
les usagers de la ratp de la sncf et des
autocars privé en ile-de-france où
l'augmentation sera de cinq et demi pour
cent en moyenne contre deux et demi en
province les progrès de la chirurgie un
homme vivant 20 khz avec un coeur de
singe par exemple ou un autre vivant
avec un brin de porc et bien c'est
peut-être pour demain
les savants anglais affirme avoir trouvé
la technique qui empêcherait les
phénomènes de rejet des greffes animal
constaté jusqu'à présent on utilise déjà
l'animal pour soigner l'homme la greffe
d'organes ce serait bien sûr un tout
autre progrès alain labouze le sens des
dindes pour la mise au point de tests
contre le tétanos l'insuline de porc
dans le traitement quotidien de
centaines de milliers de diabétiques le
sperme de hareng qui est la matière
première de la z t ce médicament qui
retarde les effets du sida et même les
valves cardiaques
encore une fois en provenance des ports
qui remplace depuis longtemps certaines
valeurs humaines défectueuse depuis
toujours les animaux sont directement
impliqués dans les progrès de la
médecine
mais aujourd'hui les chirurgiens de
l'hôpital de dulwich dans le sud de
londres vont plus loin il affirme que
dans deux ou trois ans ils seront
capables de greffer des organes
d'animaux sur l'homme un espoir immense
pour les milliers de malades qui meurent
chaque année par manque de donneurs
de plus en plus de gens veulent des
coeurs à greffer de plus en plus de gens
réclament des reins il ya une pression
dans ce sens et je pense que la
situation va plutôt empiré que
s'améliorer jusqu'à ce que l'on trouve
une solution alternative
cette solution l'équipe du professeur
bewick pense l'avoir trouvée puisque la
cyclosporine ce médicament anti rejet ne
marche pas dans les greffes intéresse s
il fallait trouver un système qui
élimine malgré tous les risques de rejet
du greffon
ils essaient de retirer les anticorps
sans doute de façon pas si pour les en
faisant passer le sang sur une sorte
d'épongé sur lequel sera fixé des tissus
de porc le sens passant régulièrement
sur cette éponge serait appauvri dans
ces anticorps qui provoque l'origine
dans un premier temps le professeur
bewick va expérimenter son filtre anti
corps sur des greffes uniquement animal
par exemple d'un port sur un mouton ou
d'un babouin sur un chien mais pour
l'homme il faudra encore attendre
oui j'ajoute à ce sujet que diverses
associations de protection des animaux
en grande bretagne ont immédiatement
protesté contre ce projet du docteur
berwick une vision d'horreur selon elle
la politique maintenant et la rentrée de
jean marie le pen le leader de l'extrême
droite fait les avances aux autres
partis de l'opposition ils proposent des
listes communes rpr udf front national
pour les prochaines municipales
à droite on fait déjà la main laurent
boussier bruno roger-petit accord edf
rpr front national partout où la gauche
est au pouvoir
la proposition de liste commune pour les
municipales faite hier par jean marie le
pen semble surtout destiné à faire
pression sur les dirigeants de
l'opposition alors que jacques chirac et
valéry giscard d'estaing sont
pratiquement partie en vacances
les dirigeants du front national reparle
d'alliance alliance qui jusqu'à présent
leur ont toujours été refusés au plan
national
l'alliance aux élections municipales est
obligatoire pour battre la gauche le
front national est incontournable c'est
une réalité
et pourtant ce n'était pas la première
fois que le front national c'est ce
genre de proposition et le rpr et l'udf
ont toujours dit non mais il s'agissait
d état-major du rpr de l'udf
là il s'agit
des responsables locaux du rpr udf qui
je pense sont des responsables de bon
sens et je crois que le bon sens
l'emportera partout mais derrière ces
propositions c'est en fait la bataille
pour la mairie de marseille qui continue
soulignant qu' ici le front national à
dix mille voix de plus que le rpr et
l'udf réunit jean marie le pen a déjà
proposé de prendre lui la tête de liste
des partis de droite
réaction immédiate de jean claude gaudin
c'est moi qui conduirait la liste udf
rpr
moi je considère honnêtement que
marseille doit choisir un maire
marseillais et que ce maire doit être en
même temps sur le plan politique sur le
plan de la gestion rassemblent pour moi
c'est clair il y aura une liste udf
rassemblement pour la république et de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui partagent
aurore le projet qu'à partir du mois
d'octobre
je développerai pour les marseillais et
basta au delà de marseille c'est toutes
les alliances locales qui sont visés par
le front national des alliances qui ont
pour but de mettre l'udf et le rpr au
pied du mur un chiffre à propos de
l'emploi l'emploi augmenté de 103 mille
personnes entre mars 87 et mars 88
pendant la même période le chômage pour
a diminué pour la première fois depuis
15 ans ce sont les résultats d'une
enquête que l'insee vient de publier la
reprise du travail aux imprimeries
didier c'est là même où il ya une
semaine de violents affrontements
avaient opposé les vigiles de l'usiné
lock out et aux syndicats une semaine
après le calme est revenu à l'adouber
style c'est sous les fenêtres de
l'imprimeur jean-didier que le syndicat
du livre cgt a fêté cet après-midi ce
qu'ils considèrent comme une victoire
on a bu le champagne en l'honneur de
l'accord intervenu entre la direction
les salariés
cet accord prévoit la réintégration de
318 salariés sur 320 le maintien de
toutes les activités sur le site de
massy
ainsi qu'un réexamen des conditions de
travail ces conditions de travail de
l'imprimerie évolué le syndicat cgt du
livre l'admet bien sûr ils pensent que
l'accord de massy servira de référence
pour l'avenir
la modernisation nous l'abordons de
manière normale avec l'ensemble des
employeurs et là il y a eu de savoir un
dérapage
peut-être un à un a priori mais à tous
toutes choses mauvaises et bien plus et
un meilleur tous les salariés toucheront
leur salaire de juin juillet
intégralement les blessés seront
indemnisés les deux salariés restés sur
la touche seront replacées par la
fédération pour la cgt ce conflit social
est un prélude à une rentrée qui sera
chaude
nous préparons à une rentrée tout à fait
grand format c'est à dire c'est à dire
mobilisation d'ailleurs voulu observer
des vacances pas de trêve estivale des
luttes partout parce que c'est
nécessaire
ça va continuer en août et la rentrée
sera d'une loi une forte mobilisation
parce qu'il ya trop de choses qui
restent en suspens et qui trop résoudre
un problème
après le meeting jean didier le
directeur recevait une délégation du
personnel bousculade pour filmer cette
entrevue
attendu depuis six semaines au programme
établissement d'un calendrier pour les
rencontres à venir mais je crois ce
devait être un jour roger bien ce fut un
jour orange je parle de la circulation
elle a été bien meilleurs que prévus
dans toute la france pour ce week end
aller-retour en vacances bison futé
prédisait le pire et bien il n'a pas eu
lieu
mais c'est peut-être justement grâce à
ses prévisions
en milieu d'après-midi le plus important
bouchon long tout de même de 10
kilomètres étaient signalés sur
l'autoroute a9 à la hauteur de la
commune d'agde dans l'hérault bien sûr
en revanche les traditionnelles
perturbations lors des grands chassés
croisés dans la région rhône alpes ne
sont pas apparus ce lundi les comédiens
et l'église il ya deux siècles on les
excommunier aujourd'hui ils sont reçus
par le pape dans sa résidence d'été de
castel gandolfo le pape a en effet reçu
la comédie française avec son nouvel
administrateur antoine vitez bien sûr
ils n'ont pas joué je n'ai ou feydeau
ils se sont contentés de quelques poèmes
de peggy gérard dalmat et nos confrères
de fr3
dans ce siècle quelle force de siècles
de chrétienté ou fascine le rachat de
nos âmes
il ya la boucherie la guerre beaucoup
d'ingratitude et de perdition
françois saignés on se disait un texte
pareil si on pouvait les diriger le pape
et bien ce soir ces réalités et puis
saint père le pape lui dire en face tu
es pierre et sur cette pierre je bâtirai
mon église c'était plus difficile que
d'habitude
non c'est à dire que j'ai j'ai retenu
mes larmes parce que ça venait trop vite
ce soir le sentiment raciste est non
seulement une pièce de théâtre une
qualité rare une liturgie sur les
hauteurs de rome castel gandolfo a donc
ouvert sont huit clos pour la première
fois des gens de théâtre
impensable il ya encore dix ans si la
résidence d'été des papes a pu être le
point de rencontre de chemin spirituel
fort différent ceux qui croient ou si
elle et ceux qui n'y croient pas c'est
parce que le texte choisi étaient eux qu
munich le mystère de la charité de
jeanne d'arc oeuvre poétique signe en
1910 par un écrivain exceptionnel
charles péguy un des grands penseurs
chrétiens pour antoine vitez nouvel
administrateur du français est justement
un de ceux qui n'y croient pas c'était
la première sortie officielle but de la
visite remercié le pape de son périple
lyonnais à l'automne 86 si tous ont pu
communier par les mots et leur émotion
c'est grâce à peggy un des maîtres de la
méditation un tout autre sujet
maintenant le modélisme vous savez les
petits avions compté les guides et bien
ce n'est pas seulement un sport c'est
aussi une formation pour les ingénieurs
et oui c'est le thème principal des
troisième fille thème le festival de la
télécommande et du modélisme reportage
télécommandé pour antenne 2 pierre-andré
lac où mathieu du conte sauvetage en
haute montagne
à ceci près que la reconstitution se
passe ici à l'échelle 1 10e
chez les modélistes c'est d'abord le
petit point fort une course automobile
n'a de sens que s'il faut une loupe pour
la suivre mais n'allez pas dire pour
autant aux modélistes qu'ils s'amusent
avec de vulgaires jouer les petites
voitures de compétition sans préparer
comme des bolides de formule 1 et au
bout de la ligne droite c'est parfois
100 kilomètres heure un spécialiste
précisera même qu'un modèle télécommande
et ce n'est pas une seule maquette mais
aussi un objet avec sa propre finalité
par exemple hier encore avec monsieur
jardin qui est le maire de la toussuire
nous discutions la possibilité
d'utiliser des modèles réduits pour
faire éclater des avalanches dans des
conditions naturelles on te fait
réglementaire
cet aperçu avec les techniciens
spécialistes du modéliste que ça ne
faisait aucun problème sans danger pour
l'homme l'avion peut alors aller tout
seul l'arc et ses explosifs
l'artificier ne connaît alors plus de
risque d'accident dans certains secteurs
comme la robotique ou s'intéressent
d'ailleurs fortement à l'emploi de la
télécommande un robot muni d'un tel
système pourrait ainsi elle est
manipulée des matières dangereuses ou
encore exercer une télésurveillance dans
une centrale nucléaire
mais avant ça la télé comme on doit
encore prouver sa fiabilité en toutes
circonstances etonnant non
dans vingt un stand en quelques secondes
vous avez rendez vous avec sophie davant
pour une météo complète à 23 heures 45
ce sera la dernière édition du journal
présenté par aubry et de l'air
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain